that simply started I guess as part of
the theme for today with others of heat
learning so I guess oh my god you have
to put human
powers compliant yeah it's like I guess
today I'll talk about the great hope and
my great disappointments also and
various efforts to try to increase the
sort of data efficiency of machine
learning and calling upon our human
friends to help us from that endeavor
so I'll discuss a few different papers a
lot related to active learning some
newer works tried to maybe deal in a
more creative way with ways that we
could inject some kind of human
interaction into a learning loop and
just sort of like standard label
querying mechanisms
and I can't I didn't have enough time
and get thumbnails properly sized for
every single collaborator but if a lot
of this work was was worked on when I
was working closely with onion on Kumar
at Amazon ai and those great interns
that we had so check them all out
they'll be yeah or accomplished
I am shortly yeah the high level idea
deep learnings great you know
stalk slide with lists of successes we
all like it
there's a kind of narrative that you
know we'd like to believe that
algorithms play some role our our
creativity as computer scientists
somehow responsible for the great feats
that we accomplished now predictive
modeling and and the reality maybe is
that we owe as much or more to the
availability of computation and large
data sets sort of explain the
capabilities that we have now versus 20
years ago and in particular this talk
I'll I'd like to focus specifically on
the data side I guess the you know the
hope is now that we have these
capabilities can we go back and achieve
some of the same feats but without
relying on so heavily on such massive
data so you know if you look at a lot of
modern systems right now computer vision
systems you know depend on millions or I
guess Facebook is pushing it out to
billions of I images sent me made a face
so it was insider information that
Google is also using millions of
photographs to train their models is our
systems use tens of thousands of hours
of annotated data typical named entity
recognition systems these hundreds of
thousands of annotated words are you
know on the order of one to two hundred
thousand annotated sentences I don't
know how many hours of self play alphago
used but it was a lot and you know our
goal here is just to say can we can we
do something
but by being a little bit smarter that's
less taxing on our interaction with the
environment and so there's a lot of
different approaches people use to try
to cope with data scarcity in particular
I'm gonna focus on active learning but
just to give a little bit of a
high-level survey you know some of the
bigger successes in getting the kind of
results that we depend on now include
data augmentation so we exploit sort of
known invariances transfer learning
between related tasks when when the
tasks are so related that they really
have the same inputs and output spaces
we describe this as a domain adaptation
problem and in particular in the NLP
world Chris book a lot about various
contextual embeddings
and now sort of semi-supervised learning
is a way that we're able to exploit a
situation where maybe input data isn't
scarce but labels for our specific task
is right so the kind of invariant the
kind of you know considerations when we
have to walk through only think about
how are we going to reduce our data
dependency our you know what precisely
is scarce is it is it our data or is it
just the labels what in variances are
there that we might be able to take
advantage of do we have access to large
label datasets for related tasks just
how related what is even the right
notion of how related and just how large
of those datasets I think a lot of these
are things that are the bread and butter
of the actual modern sort of practical
application of deep learning although to
a lot of these questions we don't even
know how to ask them properly let alone
and answer them like just what does it
mean for has to be related for in the
context of like modern transfer and then
you know ultimately what I'm gonna try
to after just fill a brief survey of
some things happening in the field is
dig more into this question of could we
do anything and it's especially smart
when we have access to annotators for
the purpose of interactively querying
labels
right so that augmentation I think even
at the time of the original image net
paper was a kind of indispensable
technique things that are six bowlers
really er way that you know sort of
transformations that we know should
preserve the label we just dumped them
into our training set alongside the
original image things like crop zooms
small rotations there's been a number of
papers we had one a bunch of other
people have done similar things in
vision this is in the context of ASR
where we start thinking about maybe for
certain types of augmentations we have
reason to believe that they shouldn't
just get the same output prediction but
we believe that these are so similar
that the model should should sort of
regard them as almost being the same
image in this case in the context of
speech recognition we were looking at
noisy speech for its regular speech
where we had you know we have access to
simple mechanisms for corrupting speech
by just using additive noise by they're
incorporating background music telephony
various kinds of aesthetic and we apply
a penalty saying that basically at every
single layer in the network we would
like the not just the the original
version and its corrupted counterpart to
to have the same corresponding
predictions but they they should
actually have the same representations
and the context to transfer learning
this is a whole lot of work now based on
this idea of you know pre train on some
source data that is for which there's
lots of lots of beta fine-tune to your
target task do this even when they're
not the same task just broadly you know
they both happen to be audio they both
option to be language they both happen
to be natural images it's so strangely
effective that I think I mean I guess
now is getting it to do in the context
of NLP but until now I mean this was for
me almost like a big mystery and machine
learned I think if we had even the
faintest idea that we could feel happy
about the kind of success we're getting
from this method it would be like the
biggest story in the world like this
really is the story of modern deep
learning in a way that we are able to
add anything else where you say you know
give me a hundred images and I'll take
you from 20 percent actor
90% accuracy I think we would have a
parade but to something just so
profoundly unsatisfying and said it all
depends upon some mysterious properties
of the initialization of these neural
networks and we don't have the faintest
idea
really why it's working we have some
stories that we tell about the feature
is being transferable and these depend
upon yet other stories about the
features being kind of hierarchical yet
we're not quite sure how to kind of
articulate crisply what we mean by this
I spoke here last time about you know
when we have really strong assumptions
about how the source and target domain
are related and they're the same task
sometimes we could actually do things
that are maybe theoretically principled
and get out you know models we could
maybe be happier about yeah we talked a
little bit about these representations
so what I like to you know focus most of
the talk on is now you know to what
extent can we think of annotation
intelligently is giving us some some
route to improve data efficiency of
machine learning in general we'll be
thinking about this kind of loop where
we have a sort of human annotator and a
model that's learning in a kind of
dynamic cycle where we have access to
some huge pool of unlabeled data and
we're gonna make some kind of choice
we're gonna have some selection criteria
that's going to decide which examples to
annotate next we'll give it to the human
human will give us a label will add the
newly labeled example to our label data
set we'll update our model and then
we'll select again and we maybe what's
missing from the picture a little bit is
that usually our selection criteria here
is somehow gonna depend upon the
intermediate model that we have after
training on some subset of the data
there's a number of variations of the
active learning setup you know we can
have this well we're gonna focus on
largely and what a lot of the literature
into the deep learning active learning
setup focuses on is this pool based idea
where we have this pool of unlabeled
instances that we're selecting from
there's also variants where you think of
this data right arriving in a streaming
fashion
or perhaps the most interesting but
least explored the idea that we would
somehow create new examples de novo with
the idea of probing the annotator with
with the example that maybe wasn't given
to us by God but yeah I mean I think the
reason why the pool based setup is so
appealing is because we can fake it
right we just take any supervised data
set and we put on a mask and pretend
that we don't see the labels and now we
say I've got an active learning problem
I don't want this to be an evangelical
talk even though I mentioned God so you
know I'll talk a little bit about some
some problems with the whole setup - and
I think you know there there's a danger
of this covering your eyes and
pretending not to see the labels on a
data set that you've already seen among
other things we'll get to is often times
when that's a very popular data set or a
benchmark data set it's already the one
that informed the choice of architecture
that you have the learning rate that you
have so we're in a setting that maybe
isn't the true setting that we would
have if we were approaching a new
problem and if we weren't approaching a
new problem you know then why the hell
were we solicit enables so some of the
basic you know considerations that we
have some of them are common to all
active learning some of them are a
little bit specific to the deep setting
one is we need some choice of an
acquisition function so how are we in
each round is going to choose which
examples to label we need to choose now
this maybe gets a little bit more
specific about the deep learning aspect
that how many how many sort of examples
how many instances from the unlabeled
pool are we going to select for query
per round in this case the reason why it
matters in the context of deep learning
is just that retraining a model when
you're talking about China neural
networks is often very expensive so we
have to actually take into account you
know how many rounds of retraining can
we afford to have so whatever our target
dataset size is this is going to give it
some trade-off between you know how much
retrain were really to do and to that
end we also have to think about things
like do we want to fine-tune our models
between rounds or do we want to train
from scratch there's been times where I
seem like training from scratch was
better
in terms of performance but if we train
from scratch every single time then our
experiments would take months to run so
we have to do something you know
absolutely horrible like every K rounds
we flush and retrain from scratch or
something like this a big problem that'd
be a recurring theme about you know the
trying to get active learning to work is
that it puts us in this setting where we
have to get things right the first time
I know is always serious in the room but
there's a conversation outdoors earlier
that even the theorists are running
experiments so it's a lot of you guys
have tried to run train a neural network
at least one time in your life and how
many of you got it to work the first
time but nothing works the first time
and so there's something extremely
dangerous about supervised learning is
this really kind forgiving problem
because it it allows you to once your
data sets constructed and you've gotten
your splits right you could just mess
everything up over and over again and
get absolute nonsense results until you
feel like you know you've kind of dialed
in you found the right learning rate
you've you know said the right prayers
but but this isn't the case in active
learning if you have a limited budget if
your whole point is that like I I can
only limit I can only label some
fraction of examples then you know you
put yourself in a tricky situation where
if you what we do in active learning
papers is we screw it up and we pretend
we didn't but in reality like if you
screw it up and you spent your budget
and you collected the wrong examples
it's over or if it's not over it's
because you lied and that wasn't your
budget in the first place in which case
why didn't you just go out and label all
the data
so there's some kind of like there's a
large body of a beautiful theoretical
work that you know unfortunately I have
not in any way contributed to on on
active learning and kind of restrained
settings we make strong assumptions
about the model class or kind of data
dependent assumptions any sort of grimy
empirical world that I spend most of my
time in there there's a handful of
heuristics that are popular a lot er
under the umbrella we call uncertainty
based sampling so there's like a the
least confidence here istic I just
looked and say among all my instances
which is the one for which the the
maximum probability prediction you know
I'm out of my predictive distribution
its lowest and I'm gonna select that one
for query there's a maximum entropy
heuristic these are the same thing in
binary classification they're not the
same thing in multi-class classification
more recently there's an interest in
leveraging sort of stochastic models
specifically like what we call Bayesian
neural networks I'll postpone a
philosophical discussion about what if
anything is Bayesian about them but the
here the idea is that if I have a
stochastic model I can sample multiple
predictions from it and look and say
basically like for each example if I
looked at the the highest vote getter
among the classes how many what fraction
of the votes did it get and I'm gonna
rank them according to that there's a
couple of popular techniques that are
sort of used widely in practice there's
this drop out method due to yarn golf
the idea is to say you're gonna train
them off model with dropout but unlike
the normal use of dropout where you're
gonna turn it off at test time and then
rescale everything you're actually just
gonna keep using it a test time and
you're gonna just sample you know a
whole bunch of separate dropout masks
you're gonna make a forward pass through
each of them and you're going to
consider the output for each different
dropout mask is a different vote and
assess your notion of confidence based
on the amount of agreement using that
sort of active learning by disagreement
heuristic
another popular approach is based on
this paper called weight uncertainty by
Blundell and colleagues this link should
take you there
from deep mind and they have this paper
where it's based on this notion of
instead of having just point estimates
on each of the way you represent each
way by a distribution so you have now a
very very simple simplifying
distribution you just say each weight is
an independent Gaussian and the way
things are going to work is the way I'll
make a forward pass through this model
is all sample a value for each of the
weights from its corresponding you know
two parameter distribution and then I'm
gonna make a forward pass through that
network so if it's hard to say you know
when you've made such a absolutely
wildly restrictive assumption about the
very variational distribution you know
what precisely you were doing at what
precisely you're estimating but these
uncertainty estimates have you know when
you make visualizations to try to
compare versus if you did something else
like bootstrapping you know what kind of
uncertainty do you get off the manifold
in simple toy cases you get something
that looks nice when you apply it in the
context of exploration for reinforcement
learning or is acquisition function it's
it's this kind of thing it's it seems
practically useful so so it's it's
become a popular technique among
practitioners whether whether or not we
sort of believe in it as a matter of
principle so you know you you wind up
with this sort of familiar situation
where you are minimizing a KL divergence
between the variational distribution and
the posterior and after some
simplification what you end up getting
is just your normal likelihood objective
plus a fancy regularizer and you know
you have a sort of hidden hyper
parameter in there which is what is you
know the variance of your prior over the
weights and that's often set not because
we have actual prior beliefs but because
we Punk it around a little bit and found
something we like
so I don't want to go too deep into it I
have uses techniques first in the
context of not active learning but in
the context of exploration in
reinforcement learning but there's a
similar objective and the goal was to
say I want to learn a policy for a
dialogue system and I want to do it with
as few interactions with the environment
as possible our motivation was you know
basically the dialogue community looked
at what was happening with dqn in the
context of Atari and alphago and got
very excited the problem is you have
this sort of pipeline here where there's
some language understanding module a
fancy way of saying flawed failing it
comes in we ultimately have to choose
what's the next action for the dialogue
system to take and then we have to
generate some corresponding utterance to
signal to the user and this piece here
we use a lot of reinforcement learning
so the slot failing in this piece here
used to be hand coded in the hope was
could we replace that with something
driven by reinforcement learning the
only problem is if you hide millions of
interactions with a human and no
customer support setting in order to get
an even slightly possible policy then
probably you already you're out of
business so it's not like playing video
games in that regard you can't just
cover your button simulation
so you know the idea here was well let's
just do Thompson sampling where either
the idea of Thompson sampling is the
alternative to Epsilon greedy
exploration is we're gonna choose each
action according to the probability that
it's the best so we're gonna use these
weight uncertainty neural networks try
to get around this fact that like the
models that were used to getting
uncertainty estimates out of like
Gaussian processes and those that sort
of get back to rate predictions which
they're all networks and you know the
best tools we have are different from
each other so we can use wait on
certainty to try to get uncertainty
estimates out of the neural networks and
use it to estimate the cue function
they're kind of a trick here like the
detail that gets a light it is like what
we're doing is actually kind of the
wrong thing what we really I guess in
discussions of uncertainty generally I
think it's very a detail that gets
alighted too often is like what are we
uncertain of and uncertainty you get out
here is uncertainty over the parameters
when you really care about maybe is
uncertainty over the cue function itself
not uncertainty over the parameters for
the cue function corresponding to the
specific policy that we have right now
so it's like we're sort of doing the
wrong thing in general but we get nice
results and a number of other people
sort of have also done something that is
similarly qualitatively wrong and you
know the same way and also got nice
results so there seems to be some some
utility at least in the context of
exploration these methods even though
we're maybe not expressing uncertainty
over the right thing so coming back to
active learning you know we were just to
seek and can we use this kind of
technique to do a much better job in the
context of you know do we really need
two hundred thousand examples assenting
scissors but how seven hundred thousand
annotated words in order to get towards
like in the ballpark of the state of the
art performance of a named entity
recognition system so the identity
recognition is just a past where we
assign a perch I can tag and these tags
indicate is this the beginning of an
entity or an internal tag in an entity
or is it some background token we can
use it to identify spans that correspond
to people to places
organizations whatever sort of the set
of entity types that are in play for
your particular task I don't know why
when I used to try to go on google image
search to find a pretty example of NER
it was something about World War two
that had Hitler in it and I went today
to try to find something more palatable
and I came up with Trump so something
that's something about NER hopefully
doesn't say anything about my search
anyway so among the the dishes that we
had here is that you know what we're
gonna do is we're gonna do is active
sampling over and over again where we're
gonna we're gonna go out we're gonna
train our model flag some examples to
add them to the data set retrain 2016
lay time-consuming so it's actually
required us to make more efficient
models so we went out and basically
figured out every single possible
component and in any our pipeline that
we could swap out a recurrent model and
replace it with a convolutional one to
give us a significant speed up several x
so basically about word embeddings that
are going to be formed at the character
level concatenated with some kind of
lookup embedding like word Tyvek this
was pre Bert well have it sentencing
coder which will also be a convolutional
model and then finally the only
recurrent connections here would be a
tag decoder which is gonna predict the
corresponding tags and it turns out that
even though beam searches are common for
this kind of thing greedy decoding does
just about as well in the context of any
are that's not necessarily true for
machine translation or ASR where the
beam really matters and so the act of
learning heuristics that we'll look at
are kind of standard and an adaptation
of like a standard uncertainty heuristic
in this case we're gonna look at
basically we're just gonna normalize our
for our least confidence heuristic we're
just going to normalize by the length of
the sequence that's because otherwise
you know you're signing up probability
to attack sequence you wind up a setting
where you're just going to be
penalized for select you're always going
to assign low probability to long
sequences because you're training
together you know the yes you have to
get more more total tokens right so we
we do instead is we just look at the
sort of like average confidence across
the sequence that's our sort of like
conventional uncertainty heuristic and
then the alternative is to use Bayesian
active learning by disagreement and so
we come away with is you know this is
our first paper so after many many
experiments and a lot of excitement we
find that with you know roughly 1/4 the
samples we could achieve 99% of the
performance that you know sort of the
best model God and these two lines here
are the performance of the top line it's
a performance of the best deep model
using all the data and the the lower
dotted line was the performance of a
shallow method using all the data
because part of what we were trying to
understand via the study is it is this
point of like if we're thinking about
deep learning versus shallow learning in
the context of being better if you have
the right amount of data the question
was well using active learning like when
can you cross that line where it's
you're better off using deep learning
than not using deep learning and how
different is that from you know if
you're not using active learning which
would be hangout tethered to something
that sort of just standard approach
where you were just you're at your data
set you know x-axis here is what
fraction of data set is annotated and so
that line there would be if you had just
selected iid as opposed to doing active
learning
so again the reality check here is that
active learning sounds great on paper
but there's this problem which is that
we have a lot of papers coming out on
active learning now that are painting a
cartoonish sort of picture of annotation
right the hindsight is 20/20 but not
foresight so what we often do is we're
in the situation where we've tried a
whole bunch of things we've found the
thing that works better than ID sampling
and then we've said that you know this
thing works but if for every single new
problem you have to try 10 different
active learning heuristics and each one
has to be able to sample a different
subset of the data and then you can go
back retrospectively and say there
exists one that does much better than
iid sampling then you're kind of in
trouble because the whole premise is
that you don't get to do that right and
then moreover there's this kind of weird
loop that the very architectures were
using the hyper parameter choices that
we're making everything is kind of
wrapped up in these same datasets that
we're using to simulate the active
learning and you know things can get
even hairier so what we did in one paper
this is at the MLP last year is we tried
to say I had a student who's just really
ferociously organised Odysseus student
and was it was able to keep track of a a
really insane amount of experiments but
we just wanted to say is hey if we just
took you know instead of this kind of
standard setting where you fix the past
you look at one to two data sets and
you'll have one particular model of
interest you know if we were to look
across a range of settings in my range
of settings I mean you know multiple
tasks you know several tasks at least
two data C speech at least three models
each and try to and then multiple runs
for every set if we were to look and try
to see how you know is desert actually
emerge a consistent story that says you
know whether active learning is
beneficial for these deep models and
interestingly you know the the results
were probably less pronounced than in
this paper but we did find that across
this wide variety of settings that
active learning seemed to give an
advantage specifically the approaches
based on these so called Bayesian
neural networks works best and it didn't
seem to be statistically a big
difference between the benefit you got
from the the dropout method in a base
buy back prop type approach how we're
doing on time by the way but I don't
know what the current time is all right
great but here's what things scale a bit
weird so then then we kind of started
thinking a little bit more critically
about I don't know I'm a practical
person and so I got I'm kind of
motivated by that can I actually use
this and the next kind of observation we
sort of had was you know what what lasts
longer datasets or models and I I think
that very often in a lot of businesses
in a lot of practical settings the data
set last longer than the model I think
it's not true of every case I think
their case is like certain recommender
systems where they're refreshing them on
a daily or weekly basis and they're
probably not changing them all that
often so I don't think this is universal
but I think it's something that we often
don't think about in terms of casting
the motivation here you know what's got
the longer shelf life and I think across
the board you know we're still using
image net granted not that's not maybe a
good example of a practical data set but
you know I think it's worth looking at
just like in our own lives you know I
think a lot of us have data sets that
we've stuck with over the course of you
know tens or hundreds of different
models coming and going and so there's
this question of like well if we're
gonna do active learning what happens
when the model goes stale like when I
when I put another model in in place of
the model that I had before am I still
going to retain the benefits of active
learning even if there are benefits in
the first place and right because you
know we have this kind of training loop
where the very selection criteria for
determining which examples to select
from the unlabeled pool are based on a
specific model that we were training at
the time and a specific you know
heuristic kind of confidence score that
we get out from that model but so we end
up coupling the data set that we collect
to the specific model or a specific
architecture that we're training the
question is well once we break that we
go out and say now I'm gonna
sample you know now I'm gonna use a
whatever like bird is the new thing you
know Ernie's next and when it when it
comes out can I use the same data set or
if I basically shot myself in the foot
by virtue of doing active learning um
sort of you know you coupling my data to
the model that I no longer want to use
the results here we're kind of
underwhelming and I think she'd be a bit
of a cautionary tale maybe for the
practical application of just naive
active learning or at least based on the
kind of currently fashionable heuristics
which are you sometimes get better you
more often do worse than when you just
have iid data when you're transferring
from from one model to another and then
another thing that was a little bit
worrying was that you know especially
since I'm author of both papers is I you
know I just wanted to kind of get to the
truth here is that I'm looking at these
results that kind of did not quite agree
with here we say let's do a large-scale
study a kind of empirical study on these
active learning approaches for a broad
range of NLP tasks and now we're saying
let's do the same thing but like what
we're specifically focusing on this
question of you know sort of the native
versus the transfer data set from you
know from the same model or versus to a
different model and we found as we even
looked at the on diagonal entries the
results were not as compelling as in the
kind of previous paper and so we spent a
huge amount of time just trying to
figure out what is the difference in
these implementations and it turns out
that although we looked across many
different models we looked across or
many different tasks many different data
sets many different models a few things
were the same among them what were the
base representations that we were
building on so apparently something
that's like seemingly innocuous or even
or sometimes like seemingly irrelevant
just to what we're investigating like
what is our choice of representation is
it Glover is it words avec could make
the difference between seeming like we
get a benefit on active learning across
all these data sets and models to
getting benefits on you know no better
than random
and I think that also is the kind of
thing that should should kind of give us
a little bit of pause and deciding you
know like what I actually I still think
it's I don't mean it's a it's a
discourage research in the area which i
think is a very different question with
it from should I actually build a
product based on this which i think is
the answer is right now no I should so
it was another other approaches out
there based on pseudo labeling based on
kind of heuristics that have to do with
the gradients at all kind of leave off
for now so so then you know I like to
talk about some other papers where
you've tried to maybe think about
annotation in a broader way and maybe
try to be a little bit more creative
with it
so you know there's this pattern and of
active learning papers where we just
sort of say we take an example we send
it to the adult theatre and they give us
a label and we're doing something like
multi-class classification like imagenet
we just give them an image and they just
come back and say like this is a Persian
cat that's not how the imagenet data set
was created though that's not actually
so to speak how the sausage gets made
real labeling isn't like you just say
give me the label out of this ontology
of a thousand categories he's never
heard of and they just come back and
tell you the precise one is often
consists of asking a whole bunch of
simple often binary questions and what
we wanted to do is kind of change the
view from thinking about annotation in
terms of the number of examples that we
query to thinking about a realistic view
of the annotation procedure and thinking
about how many questions we have to ask
so in the case of imagenet this is how
it was actually created is that they got
they had a set of categories that was
like they were able to create and if
anyone's in the room was like actually
involved in gradient you could correct
me it's like anything wrong but my
understanding for me in the papers they
had an ontology that came from the
wordnet hierarchy which gave him this
like sort of hierarchy of nouns and then
they were able to use the creative step
there's these Google image search to
sort of filter a set of candidates of
images that were likely to belong to
that category and then the primary use
of the crowd workers wasn't to say
here's an image give me one of a
thousand categories it was to ask them
binary question
like say here's an image is it a Persian
cat or not and then you're just you know
in this very familiar kind of more
classical crowdsourcing setting where
you're asking a binary question you have
votes and you know you could you could
do a majority vote you could try to
model like individual work or quality
jointly with estimating the labels to do
something like that but you know becomes
a sort of classical sort of crowdsource
binary feedback across a crowdsourcing
problem so we try to think of as you
know if I do have an image and I want to
sort of like feed it to an annotator and
I want to get a label and I've got some
some sort of multi class data set likely
I'm not able to just ask them what's the
label but I have to ask them some kind I
have to drill through some kind of set
of binary questions is maybe a more
plausible feedback mechanism so we were
working with a subset of it imagenet
called tiny imagenet and it because it
does derive from this wordnet hierarchy
of concepts we were we do actually have
this this this tree that we could drill
through and so our our idea was to sort
of to say could we do something where we
think of active learning not just as a
matter of selecting samples but a matter
of jointly selecting like which example
to feed to the annotator
and also what question to ask them so a
query consists of like an image and a
category and that category could be like
a leaf category from the hierarchy but
it could also be something higher up so
you can say is this a domestic animal is
this a dog is this a cat is this a
natural object or artificial object you
might go all the way all the way up the
hierarchy and so the idea here is you
start off with unlabeled data we have
some hierarchy over classes we're gonna
choose a question where we define
question here as an example class pair
where the class could be a super classic
it doesn't have to be one of the one of
the Leafs nodes and the annotate is just
going to give binary feedback and at the
end of the day after we ask one query
what we have is we call partial label so
we've been able to rule out some some
branch of the tree and then we have some
set of query we have some set of classes
that may apply so
set of classes that definitely don't
apply and now we can continue asking
questions based on the same example we
did throw that one back into the pool
and pick another example where we're
gonna choose both you know the image and
the query and we sort of a few things
that we now need to take into
consideration one is when we have these
partially labeled examples how do we
update our models based on the partial
feedback and then our goals here are
sort of twofold one way we can think
about it is to say that if I fix any
number of any budget sort of like the
classic active learning setup rather
than fixing the budget in terms of the
number of examples labeled if I fix my
budget in terms of the number of
questions asked how do I get out the
best classifier or the second question
here is I could say if my goal is to
eventually annotate the entire dataset
how do I do that with while asking the
fewest number of questions so you know
the kind of intuition here could be
something like if the model you know if
the if I feed in an image you know some
midpoint and training and the model is
already sure that it's either a dog or a
cat like the zero probability assigned
to the possibility that it's a bird that
it's a monkey wrench that it's
automobile then at that point I don't
need to waste time asking questions sort
of above the level of hierarchy where
the model sort of already does not
believe there's any sort of plausible
chance that the cat er there's important
you know questions to ask independently
or offline about you know how much stop
you want to put in the outputs that come
out of neural networks in terms of
thinking of them as degrees of belief or
probabilities but I'm gonna punt on that
so you know we consider a set of
sampling strategies one idea is to look
at these sort of expected information
gains so like based on based on the
predicted probability is assigned to
each class we think if I were to if I
were to ask this yes-or-no question
about one of the knows in the hierarchy
and I were to get back an answer
according to the probabilities that I've
already signed to that you know the
right class being within that
superclass they're sort of you know what
do i what is vai sort of expected
reduction in entropy of the predictive
distribution upon you know getting that
answer right when I get back that answer
I'm going to find out that some subset
of classes are just ruled out and some
other subset are feasible and I'll just
rescale my probabilities accordingly so
I want to know you know what's the
expected it's sort of information data
reduction entropy and we look at some
other heuristics like you know one that
just tries to decrease you know across
the data set the number of potential
classes that could apply to items as
quickly as possible and the other one
that tries to sort of label as quickly
as possible so expect the number of
remaining classes is going to look for
each example and it's going to try to
choose the one that's going to get it
closest to an exact label it's basically
it's trying to procure exact labels as
quickly as possible so we got these
results I mean they're in a way
encouraging and discouraging so so it
turns out asking active questions so in
this case we're looking at top one
accuracy versus Hort of the number of
sort of bits of information solicited
from the annotator when we find the
active questions and the active would
call just active learning a partial
feedback which is basically like
questions selecting both the questions
and the examples both do sort of much
better you know for a fixed number of
questions and the iid baseline purely
just doing active learning without doing
the active questions so in this case
that means that like you're gonna
solicit the you're gonna you're gonna
solicit the label in the naive way
you're just gonna drill through the
hierarchy you're not going to be
intelligent about how you select the
question only about how you select the
example the you know traditional active
learning heuristics don't do very well
here but being smart about which
question you ask actually does and here
what we look at over time instead of
looking at accuracy is we look at what
fraction of the of the dataset has been
exactly labeled as a function of the
number of queries that we've run so we
find that you know when we do the active
questions we
do label the data set much more quickly
yeah then it's this time I use the same
predictor over and over again for every
example that comes it occurs very faster
well he'll it looks like those questions
are tailored around the test example so
you have two training examples oh so
these are for the training right so like
I start off with a classifier that's
random it's gonna assign near uniform
probabilities to everything I'm gonna go
I don't really have much way of
disambiguating so I'll probably choose
some example I don't really have much
basis so they're almost the same and I'm
asking questioning at the top of the
hierarchy and then over time yeah it's
going to but but when we report accuracy
we're reporting accuracy on held-out
data that was never seen at any point
during this procedure yeah yeah so I see
about five minutes use enter or all
right it's great so another thing that
we started looking at was about
crowdsourcing and you know in what way
we could integrate learning and
crowdsourcing so the classical kind of
crowdsourcing setup this is I have a
bunch of data points these are some so
maybe dudes are something like this and
I have you know imagine that it's just a
binary classification problem then each
annotator is going to give me some vote
is it you know belong to the positive or
the negative class and I'm going to then
basically try to jointly learn I'm gonna
you know the naive thing I could do is
majority vote and then the slightly
smarter thing I could do is I could try
to jointly learn the noise profiles of
each of my workers and infer the real
labels so I learned this worker happens
to disagree with their comrades more
often than others so I start lowering
the you know confidence that I have in
that worker and over time you know as a
result that's gonna change my inference
of what's the correct label and then if
I were to go back and reinforce and so
they have some kind of PM algorithm
based on this model by bell we'd scale
but they actually these models ignore
the features themselves they don't look
at the examples and as a result
basically if you have singly labeled
data so if you have each example is only
assigned to one annotator then these
models collapse on saying that all the
workers are perfect like in the absence
of disagreement they can't model but
basically what are our approach to this
model was basically to to say you know
we're addressing a few questions one is
even when the data is singly labeled can
we still both estimate worker quality
and estimate the labeling function and
yeah and and then more broadly we're
kind of interested in shedding light
into this fundamental question of you
know what is this trade-off between so
what people normally do is they pick
some number of times to have every
example labeled you know they pick some
number K that's chosen who knows
heuristically
you know maybe I'll have every example
labeled five times and they go out and
they have some big data set and you know
whatever their budget is you know
presumably examples themselves like
images are cheap and what they have is
whatever their budget is divided by five
or divided by seven or divided by three
whatever is their level of redundancy
that's the number of examples they could
label and we wanted to sort of shed some
light into this question of how do you
trade off the redundancy with which you
label items worse than the number of
items that you can afford to label and I
guess the spoiler is that in our setting
what we tend to find is that actually
you're most often better off having as
much noisily labeled data as possible
like you're better off saying I'd rather
have a million examples labeled one time
each than a hundred thousand a hundred
thousand labeled ten times each and I'll
eat the noise I'll figure out how to
deal with the noise and maybe
intuitively it kind of makes sense
because you think if I were to take a
single example and keep labeling it over
and over and over again it's obvious at
some point that you have diminishing
returns but maybe what's less obvious is
what happens when you only have three
labels or it's four or five
so we have a bunch of synthetic examples
you know I'll kind of just kind of go
through the highlights because we don't
have too much time left is the the key
idea of the algorithm is what we're
gonna do is we're going to use
disagreements between the workers and to
learn the model to estimate their sort
of worker confusion matrices we're gonna
then take those worker confusion
matrices and this is going to we're
gonna go back and relearn our model but
giving more or less credence to the
labels these are the awaiting mechanism
based on how noisy we think each worker
is to get out yet a new model and then
go back take the new model relearn Rhian
further the worker confusion matrices
there's some caveats related to
generally the effective importance
weighting that's come up in more recent
work that i've done that you know makes
me want to kind of revisit this and see
if we could do something that'll make
more sense in the context of deep
learning but in practice it tends to
work pretty well and what you find is
this these plots over here this is on C
far that you know this is the degree of
redundancy and when we have a sixth
annotation budget we find almost always
that once you know you get you get your
best performance that somewhere either
one or two annotations for example but
very quickly as you increase the level
of redundancy your model gets worse yeah
so the key idea here is that you're
going to insert the model in as like a
stand-in for consensus so you're gonna
learn a model on noisy labels compare
the model to the workers disagreement
with a model sort of constitutes like
disagreement with the consensus and
we're gonna think you use annotators who
disagree the model more often than other
annotators are noisier we're going to
take this into account then we're going
to use this to like update our waiting
to give less credibility to their
examples relearn our model then take the
new model go back compare with the
workers again so it's like you could
think of it as like doing a classical
crowdsourcing like 'i'm typing only the
rather than comparing workers to each
other based on daemon this disagreement
on examples they both annotated is that
we're going to use the model itself is
like the stand-in for the consensus and
so
some theoretical results under you know
kind of classical settings but we have a
capacity constrained model and deep
learning we're sort of left you know in
the in the usual precarious situation we
are for for you know having to rely on
empirical support so anyway I think I
think that's about where we are timewise
kind of kind of really interested in now
is this question of can we use
annotators to do something yet more wild
so in the context of sentiment analysis
I was kind of Justin's question just
what actually is sentiment and we often
speak of it as though there's this
disentangle thing but the question was
can we actually have humans go and
rewrite movie reviews to like turn the
sentiment knob like make this a positive
review make it a negative review
instructed not to make gratuitous
changes and we have some interesting
results about what happens when you then
learn on the original versed sort of now
like counterfactual like you know these
reviews verse learning on both but among
other interesting things you find that
there's certain things that I think NLP
community likes to call artifacts which
is like anything that is a correlation
you don't like but you find things if
you look at movie reviews that Romantic
means very positive and horror means
very bad but if you after you do this
like those types of kind of surprising
associations disappear from the data set
Mateus is telling me I'm done and I am
done so anyway huh anyway thank you
[Applause]
of all the things happening in deep
learning that are could potentially
generate fake news I don't know that the
particular works presented in this talk
are the highest risk
I am worried in general about the
capacity of this technology maybe not so
much in terms of synthesizing text which
is what the media went crazy over it
maybe a little bit more in terms of the
ability to create for amateurs to create
like forged photographs but I don't know
that my work is really in the right zip
code in this case you know the process
for changing the movie review as a human
is editing a movie review so this is
actually like the human who's doing that
changing what we're hoping to do is you
know reduce our dependence on things
that really aren't semantically tied to
the quality of the review but they're
just you know you know I guess we would
like to call it spiritually associated
or something okay I'm sure we'll take
the other question offline let's have
lunch we'll come back into 15
[Applause]